guys I want to take a second that call
awhile ago
um guy brought up something not about us
but just in general that I haven't
touched on in a while around here and I
think it's time I touched on it again
I'm not seeing as much of it as I saw
maybe two years ago but there's a
problem let me back up okay all the data
tells us that your ability to become
successful whether it's in wealth
building or parenting or in your
marriage or in your career your ability
to be successful ends up being heavily
influenced by who you hang around with
we all know that we become who we hang
around with like I was in New York City
a while back and about about three or
four months ago doing a TV show up there
and I noticed that those people all have
accents you become who you hang around
with I mean if those Yankees move south
pretty soon we'll teach them how to talk
right I mean you become who you hang
around with don't you if you're if the
kid down the streets misbehaving little
Johnny is a weed head you don't let your
kid run around little Johnny because you
know your kid will be a weed head right
and guess what the same is true with you
you use the same good words and bad
words that your friends use you have a
tendency to read the same books see the
same movies live in similar properties
with similar color on the walls you tend
to wear the same clothing that your
friends where you tend to have the same
beard treatment that your friends have
if you do beard treatment got a bunch of
hipsters working here and they got all
the beard treatment going on so I'd make
fun of them all the time because I'm old
I don't need a beard treatment just keep
mine cut with some Sam's cutters but you
become who you hang around with don't
you now you got to be careful with that
because what happens is it affects your
belief system as well and so if you
start hanging around with all the time
people that believe that you can't get
ahead ever hear people say things like
oh you can't get ahead in America today
the
man can't make it in America today you
hear people say that of course they
always flying when they're saying it I
grew up with some people acting like
that all the little man the little man
can't get ahead well the Lord can man
the working man the little man can't get
ahead I hope the president or fix
everything for the little man because
the little man and you know and they
always like a or is their spirit animal
you know they're waiting on some
exterior force to fix their life they
watch The Lone Ranger and Batman too
many times and they think that someone
is the Calvary is actually coming it's
not it's not coming there's not an
outside force that's going to fix your
life and oh by the way there's not an
outside forces holding you back 98% of
things that hold you back are between
your freaking ears it's your own
decision that holds you back
it's our insecurities that we all have
it's our fears that we all have it's our
lack of work ethic that we all have it's
our lack of perseverance that we all
have and this is what holds us back you
know I was told when I got in radio that
a southern accent you couldn't make it
in talk radio we're the third largest
talk radio show in America I was told in
talk radio you couldn't make it if you
weren't owned by one of the large
corporate companies and runs all the
radio stations
we're the third largest talk radio show
in North America and we owned it was
told that if you're going to make it in
talk radio you had to be in Los Angeles
or New York to syndicate the show out of
I still live in Nashville I like
visiting LA and New York periodically
but the chance of me living in either
one those places is zero shoot me and
get it over with
seriously I love you people to live
there I'm glad you like it I'm not
living there period so that's it and
guess what we're the third largest show
and talk radio I was told a
self-published book can't make it and
I've sold millions and millions and
millions of copies of self-published
books I was told dot dot dot dot dot dot
there's always something there's always
somebody telling you you can't make it
because of your background because of
your history because of your family
because of the color of your skin
because you're a woman because you're a
man because you're from the south
because you're from the north because
you're an immigrant because you're not
an M
you can't make it there's always
somebody that's got some excuse for you
to not make it well you know you're not
you're not pretty you don't understand
you got white privilege well tell that
to the two Ramsay personalities that are
highly successful that are black that
will be anthony o'neill and chris hogan
does anybody notice no nobody gives a
rip what your skin color is there's a
few idiots out there that are still
prejudiced morons but most people just
care if you care and if you care about
them and if you actually are competent
at your job that's what most people care
about and that's not white privilege as
Chris or ask Anthony now you can't make
it if you're a woman I'll ask Rachel
Cruz and Christy right the other 2/3 as
you notice that there's six Ramsey
personalities including me and only two
white men in the bunch that will be me
and Chris Brown you know the rest of
them are minorities just struggling
along okay they don't have any privilege
that just are highly successful is all
that's all that's all they're just why
because they're highly competent they
care and they work with extreme
diligence and you can do that on the
stage off the stage in the spotlight not
in the spotlight and again are there
some idiots that won't let a lady speak
somewhere yeah there are that's fine
that's fine
are there some people that discriminate
against me won't let me speak in their
church because I'm white yep now you can
count on it that's happened before I had
one wouldn't let me speak because I
wouldn't wear a tie cuz I don't own one
there you go I'm left
I'm tie I have a tie inferiority complex
now because I don't own the time problem
was I don't care um because it's not
relevant you become who you hang around
with and if people tell you oh they're
structural flaws with the economy oh you
have the deck stacked against you so you
can't make it and these are people of
influence in your life and you begin to
believe that politically correct garbage
then you will act on that belief and you
will therefore not be successful
so don't believe that and if you're
hanging around too many people that talk
and think that way you're going to
become one of them
and it's going to hamper your success
it's always interesting to me that one
of these people who's not supposed to be
able to make it who believes in the
political correct garbage become
successful they don't know what to do
with it they don't know how to mentally
how to mentally process that and so
because it's so inconsistent with their
belief system they weren't supposed to
be able to make it and yet they did make
it and so it screws up their brains let
me just tell you you got to be careful
what you're feeding your brain on that
stuff because you become who you hang
around with if you say well there's
structural flaws with the economy and
you know the stock market the rate of
return on the stock market and you can't
get a house in today's world you know
you're just the chances to advance and
you know if you're 57 and you get laid
off you're just screwed because nobody
hires anybody in the 50s in their 50s
you know how much we age discriminate
around here it's a zero we hire people
based on what we think they can do the
job and part of whether we think they
can do the job is do they have a or is
their spirit animal and so you come in
here where your lip all stuck out
whining about your lot in life I can
pretty much freaking guarantee you we're
not going to hire you see you just
effected your future with your belief
system see how that works it's very real
it's very very dangerous so when people
start showing such throwing sexism
racism privilege and those kinds of
things around be very careful who you're
hanging out with because it'll affect
your ability to win if you believe that
crap this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
down
[Applause]
[Music]